[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
the politicians should realize
the power of the people and they should
listen to the people's
commands
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is unclear at the moment is how the
prime minister is making these decisions
the prime minister has only particular
pass he does not have the power to
declare himself acting president nor
does he have the power to declare a
state of emergency
so these are extremely uncertain
developments in sri lanka protests that
started a few months ago were very clear
with their demand go home go tell a bear
go home ranch boxes and more recently go
home runner
[Music]
[Music]
we need to get a government that the
people have trust in
we want an all-party government to be
appointed very soon and we were hoping
that would happen but it is uh but now
this this this maneuvering that is
taking place suggests that these all
these processes will be delayed which is
very bad for us because we need to have
a stable
cohesive government soon to be able to
get out of the economic morass that we
are in
[Applause]